and uh
basically what we do is we download a
bunch of mobile apps
we don't have the source code obviously
we strip them apart see what's in them
see what they do
um this tool was designed to kind of
get at these queries a lot faster
basically there's this thing called byod
bring your own device companies they
don't care if you bring
your phone to work anymore but they want
to make sure that
nasty stuff isn't on it um so things
that our customers care about
stuff like seeing the you did sin and
the clear seeing the address book sent
out sending the email archives in and
out
i bet half of you guys who work with
mobile apps i could
probably talk on the security of
them but that's besides the point
um this is an abbreviated list obviously
we have
thousands of signatures to look for
crappy security policies
that developers do once again we don't
have the source code to your apps we
have to break them open
uh you know we use stack analysis
dynamic analysis here you're seeing some
smaller
some class methods that we're looking at
specifically this is ad-lib adware
whether it's adware or not besides the
point
dynamic analysis is a screenshot from a
dev environment that i
took earlier today we we literally load
these apps up on mobile devices
run them through you know rent some
money monkey runners on them and so
forth
and collect this data so this is this is
the problem that i'm setting up
we're collecting all this data on the
apps right now we have like five million
apps
in our collection that we've downloaded
from the markets they're from third
party markets
we have all these different signatures
that we're collecting on them
you know that that we showed so where
does this data go and where can
where can we query it from as you can
tell this is not go
so so you'll see these little
methods spread all throughout the code
but what you'll note is it's a single
app set membership it's not on an entire
collection
it's actually not like an easy problem
to do
and so so we have these
of course then you have joe bob boss and
he has this random ass query of the day
i like all the apps that connect to
dropbox persist text messages and send
all and clear back to the servers
you'd be surprised about how many apps
actually do this and don't care
um so we've run these queries and these
queries just take like
you know a long time to run and it's
it's not efficient it's not efficient to
store it's not efficient to query it's
just a pain in the ass
um so after a while i was like well you
know how long does this take you know 40
seconds to get the cardinality
of one signature that's that's insane
you know we we need these answers
like this we need it sub second um
so we started kind of like looking
around but of course
to do that you really have to define
your problem first to jump into a
problem
without really defining it is really
stupid
so what we're looking at right now and i
know i didn't label the x y axis
i i understand but uh this is a
distribution
of our signatures versus the number of
apps
that stuff in the upper right corner
those are obviously like
really bad because they're so out there
that
they their their meaning is completely
lost
um so graphing your data like this will
give you
quite a bit of insight but this is this
was the first thing before we
wrote a single line of code was let's
figure out what this data really is
because we had never really looked at it
as a whole
we had just kind of been like oh well
you know facebook it connects to
facebook you know and
they're they're you know sending that
you did in the clear and all this sort
of stuff
um but to get this like real set
identification that was kind of like
what we're
looking for five million apps thousand
signatures
you know one signature might might be
tempting to rip your
root your phone another one send in the
location all those different location
based apps that are just sending back
all sorts of stuff
you know uh the other one you know it
eats little kittens
um so so what
what did i want to achieve here well i
wanted i wanted a networkable daemon
right
obviously um it needs to perform these
large in-memory
data set operations you're andy and your
ori
directory and you're nodding all this
stuff it needs to deal with concurrency
in like a really decent manner you know
i don't want to just sit there and
go into template l right um
obviously not ruby most of the code in
our shop is ruby
there's a portion of the c plus portion
of subjective c all that sort of stuff
uh so we go go
uh we got a couple main components in it
right we have this http layer
basically it just sits there and listens
for requests we got this query layer
this is the query engine i kind of come
from more of a
grammar background so when i mean query
it's
a bit tap it more than select star um
persistence obviously that can be very
tricky when you combine all these
different things together
um so just kind of jumping in and this
is not
idiomatic go code at all this is kind of
like crap
i just pasted in but anyways
i figured the best thing to show was the
testing that go provides right out the
door
is excellent um you don't have to
install
rspec you don't need to install cucumber
you don't need all these like
third-party
you know gym masks you just kind of get
going in coding right away
and this is you know in so many lines of
code you can kind of
test this expectation same thing with
query you know let's do a
let's do a grand balance check
very very quick and easy to do
well once again our parser in fixed
notation no one's going to try to
write the others this is kind of like
what we were trying to go towards
where we could write something like this
and then output
you know our cardinality or i'll put the
entire set
in a json response uh
right now you have you have something
that is dirty as this
obviously we're kind of looking for a
sweeter dsl
but this is this is kind of where we're
at at right now
um but just keep in mind
this query earlier for one of those was
about 40 seconds
so if i wanted to get the cardinality of
14099 i don't know what the hell that is
that that might be like um i don't i
don't know emails your cat at midnight
every night i don't know what it means
but uh let's let's say that that was
like 40 seconds to query on right now
well right now that query came back in
100 microseconds or
whatever that is 0.01 um so we get our
cardinality and we get our list
and now we can actually go back to the
guy
that uh the the gilbert cartoon guy and
we'd be like oh by the way
here's the answer to your query
obviously you can do this with many
languages
but go presented many things that
allowed us to do this
in a very fast and efficient manner not
not just because it's statically typed
not just because it's a compiled
language not just
all this other stuff but because of the
development efficiency
i don't have to like go out and figure
out all this crap
libraries that some other third-party
coder wrote because
it's easier you know it's not easier uh
this is easier
some takeaways go format go test data
like
type compiled right there the test
suites
i'm not i'm not gonna say it's 100
covered i mean this is
this is pivotal so like i won't just
like sit here and lie
you know i mean but seriously if this
was a c plus plus program
you know i mean that that would be so
much longer
you know tested compiled everything
uh this was supposed to be like a five
minute ten minute thing
so anyways just just kind of like a go
success story
we uh we really enjoyed it and we kicked
this product out
in like less than i don't know less than
a month is basically one of those
christmas projects
so
so ncd so on on
i'll give some background first on
coreos so coreos is a new linux
distribution and sort of where we
started with it
we looked around at how people are
actually using linux operating systems
in production and a lot of times they
aren't really taking a lot of
the packages or a lot of the effort that
these
these vendors are putting into the
operating system and using it as is
they package up all the dependencies
whether it be like node.js or java or
whatever
and so the application's pretty pretty
well removed
pretty well removed from the actual base
operating system
and so it kind of gave us an opportunity
to think about
what a linux operating system might be
if we could design it slightly
differently because
people are more and more moving their
applications away from
the actual os one of the first things
that we wanted to do was sort of
build something that could perhaps help
the security
stance that a lot of people have around
their operating systems they oftentimes
will
you know every once in a while think
about remembering that last time they
ran the update
upgrade or outget update and it might
have been a really long time since
they've rebooted their machine
and so what we wanted to do is kind of
move to a push model where we
act more like the browsers like chrome
or firefox where updates actually get
delivered to your servers and that's
part of why the consumer internet has
moved
so quickly in the last few years and why
security on the consumer internet's
improved so well in the last few years
is because these browsers are able to
push
and so we try to think about how we
could do that on the server
and what we arrived at is we're going to
be rebooting a lot of people's servers a
lot of time
and what that meant was we needed to
build a
data store something like uh
like the chubby paper at google or
zookeeper or something like this and
we didn't set out to build this
originally it just came out of what we
needed to do
in order to build uh coreos so what etcd
is is it's um
it's a highly available key value store
for shared configuration
and service discovery and so immediately
everyone has this perfect picture of
exactly what i'm talking about in mind
right um probably not true so i'll walk
you through um
what it means uh the first is going to
be the super contentious one
um among distributed systems people of
what i mean by highly available so let's
get that out of the way
um yeah it's apache license written and
go which is why
i'm here so um highly available
means in this case uh that it's a
partition tolerant
but so say we have this five node
fcd peers it's currently the cluster is
available
and we're able to write to it it's
available and we're able to write to it
it's available we're able to write to it
it is unavailable and we
can only read from it and that's what i
mean by highly available
is that a certain number of the nodes
quarantines
have to be um if they're up then you're
able to write
fcd um it's a key value store
so if you're familiar with
zookeeper it has a similar layout
or even the unix file system
so you have directories and underneath
directories you have
actual value nodes
so uh everything is called the node um
sort of somewhat following the unix
tradition of like dinos and inodes but
um there's there's directory nodes and
there's value nodes
and uh the value can just be a simple
string um a lot of people end up
encoding
json or whatever into that value
but it can be whatever you want and so
uh what what what is this useful for so
we have this
kind of file system thing that we can
write to
what it's really useful for is is shared
configuration
so i need to share this bit of data
whether it be like a password or
you know some configuration values of
what hosts
uh you should be contacting for this
particular service et cetera
um and then discovery of services so you
may have a directory that's a bunch of
back-end web servers that need to be
inserted into a load balancer or
something
um but it turns out that discovery is
usually not enough
you can't just like dns is is discovery
right you can just publish information
but oftentimes applications are more
complicated than that they can't just
get a list of ips
and that's going to be enough for you to
do everything you need to do around
services you also need locking
which means that you need to be able to
change a value atomically and have that
value viewable throughout the rest of
the cluster
so um that's that's sort of why we had
to build build lcd we can't just like
build it on
a cache or a or something is
you need the atomic nature of the thing
um so here's a simple
we're going to just run through a simple
example of how an application with that
ct might work
so application comes up and it says
where's my db
there's not up yet so it's like ftd
response sorry there's no database
so the application says or agent on
behalf of the application says okay i'll
just wait
and watch on a directory for
databases to come up and then postrest
comes up and there's an agent
acting on behalf of postgres where
postgres has logic built into it
it says is there a db master yet
and ncd says sorry there's no db master
so you're it all right make sure you
come up in master mode
um and so the application has been
sitting there
watching on this key for a database it
says a database appeared
and so it can now start making database
queries it's like yes select star from
awesome and
uh the postgres or an agent on its
behalf starts heartbeating
saying i'm alive i'm alive i'm alive um
and this is everything's fine like the
the
application came up everything's being
registered and coordinated through fcd
so uh the application continues to watch
and postgres continues to heartbeat say
it's alive
a new postgres node comes up and it says
can i need to be master
please and uh etv replies
fcd has a leader election api
edc replies through the leader election
api
sorry master exists and you
he is sitting here so you need to talk
to him about you know getting your wall
file
and um setting yourself up into slave
mode
um meanwhile he starts heartbeating um
nothing's really changed the application
uh you know there's been no leader
change
so heart beating's happening and
everything's fine
the application is stable you're not
getting paged
so everyone's really happy uh
dang it there's been a horrible no
partition aws is down
something bad has happened um so
heartbeats stop arriving to fcd
uh and what happens here is that
the leader election api that it's
heartbeating too
the slave's heartbeating too finally
notifies it after a ttl
um i have some bad news you
are now the new master and the
application has been watching on the
database
key and sees that there's a new database
a new master in town
reconfigures itself and once again is
able to run its queries
so the partition goes away
the whole cycle begins again you know
the the new
node comes back up after the partition
it's like
okay it asks if it can become master it
gets denied
and um things are good so uh
it's not generally enough to just have
discovery you also need to
have things where um there's a
consistent view of the cluster
so you can do things like master
election or say i need x number of these
workers out in the cluster
i need to configure this elastic ip on
aws to this one node you can't
eventually consistent
on an elastic ip right like there's one
ip it's one resource
somebody has to own it okay so which
brings
that's that's how sort of ftd works now
we'll get into the interesting bits is
the underlying technology
and algorithm the the algorithm that we
use is called raft
it's a paper that came out from a phd
student from stanford i believe last
year
he published the paper diego
and uh diego is currently writing
his thesis and i got really good news
from diego a few weeks ago
he said that he had to change his pdf
viewer because
scrolling was too slow so that means
he's making really good progress
the pieces is getting long enough that
he may just graduate
so yeah it
i don't like nobody understands pax i
don't understand access
so i i couldn't tell you well enough i
it gives you the similar
uh guarantees to paxos um and so it's
it's similar to like zab
i've been told which is zookeepers
underlying protocol i mean the reason
diego wrote draft is because you
he as a phd student had a difficult time
understanding consistent algorithms
and me as a lowly engineer has never
understood since his algorithms before i
read the wrath paper
um and so the the entire paper is trying
to build an understandable consistence
algorithm
and i think he did a pretty good job
because there's about 30 different
implementations in various languages
now of of the raf consensus algorithm
yeah it's been published and there's um
several open source ones
i'm actually going to talk about the go
wrap library
which you can use to build things
so yeah it's about building or having a
consensus across multiple machines right
so
every node in the cluster has the exact
same value or
in cases perhaps a value that had been
previous but they're not
it's not like eventually consistent it's
like hard consistent
um so one one nice thing that's happened
in the raft community is how do i exit
this is interesting
i can only go forward
this has never quite happened
huh
it only lets me go forward i'm going to
the end
okay
so one of the go wrapped authors
ben b johnson created this thing called
the secret lives of data.com
which is really helpful because it
provides some basic
some basic visualizations of raft and
some other consensus
algorithms and distributed systems
algorithms um
and so in this example we have like we
have a three node raft cluster
and um what we're going to do is just go
through and do like a basic master
election and visualize it
and then also build a consensus on a
single value
so this is a single node
and a node in raft can either be in a
appear or a follower state
which is visualized by having no border
um it can be in a
it can be in a um in a candidate state
which means that it's uh it's put in its
uh
a vote to the cluster and it's trying to
become the leader
or a leader state which means that a
quorum of the cluster has
said yes we think that you are uh
are a great leader um
so yeah it's sort of like democracy and
algorithm
so um what we'll see here is one of the
nodes
turns into a candidate and it puts out a
vote request
to the other nodes in the cluster
the nodes then say yes we agree
you can become the leader then he's in a
leader state
and so this means that he all rights get
routed through the leader
so what will happen next is we'll get a
um
a client and the client would like to
write five into the data store
or into the log in this case and
um so he gets a command that says set
five
the leader gets command that says set
five and it distributes out
distributes this um to all the other
peers in the cluster they say okay we
got set five
leaders like okay the new value is five
and then it tells everyone else to
commit this value
once it's been committed to the log then
we can now finally reply back to the
client okay
um we got your request and
the new value of the cluster is five or
of the value is five
so that's basically how the the raft
algorithm works
at a low level great
i'm on the last slide
okay uh so that that's how it works
let's just dive into some code and see
how etcd actually works
so what i have here is um i brought up
a cluster of three machines um in tmux
so this this here is um the
the first pier pier one and then it's
pier two and then pier three
uh and it's just dumping a bunch of logs
um so if i was to
say like nuke one of them it's going to
start panicking and saying
heartbeats have failed to appear too
and i'll start him back up and
everything's fine so
uh and ftd has some nice things where we
can actually visualize the cluster a bit
so we have obviously this is all running
on localhost so i'm getting really
killer latencies here
um but like on aws it does not look so
good
um so those numbers spike
readily and um we also have a little key
browser i don't have any keys
in this database yet because i just are
in this cluster because i just
started it but we have a little
dashboard
for you to play around with and the cool
thing about this is this is all just
client-side code
since ncd uses an http interface and
json we actually this is just old
angularjs and jquery and
um stuff so that's that
um so we've brought up a fcd cluster
and we can um you know nuke individual
nodes
and we can see that like failure counts
start increasing
as the leader is panicking because
append entry requests aren't getting
applied
um and heartbeats are failing um
and then we you know stabilize the
cluster again and things stop failing
everything's good kind of acts how you
you would expect
um so that's an scd cluster
uh and the api is rather straightforward
using the
scdctl which is the command line utility
built on gotcd
which is the client api uh library
and so we just set this this key called
configurationdb
with some json payload and you can see
we can start to actually look at the api
a little bit
by adding the debug flag which gives us
out an actual curl
line um so if we wanted to
and the quoting was right thing then we
could have
ran that through curl here we'll do
something like git
and then
cool so it just acts as a regular http
client with some
additional smarts um and that that's
one of the the clients to at ce
um and the the api is fairly restful
it's as restful as we could really get
um
by trying to like push a file system on
top of like http semantics
um it's a little difficult to map that
cleanly
so like you you get to like data value
you
use git http git verb to
put a value or to set a value you put
and then we have invariants like only
set if the index
the index is like the logic clock within
the fcd cluster so
you can say things like only set this
value if the index is equal to like 117
or something
all right so uh gotcd is the library
that you can use from go to
do this to interact with that cd um
and instead of like diving through and
giving you the full like view of
what the client can do it does what
you'd expect there's get functions of
their set functions and there's
set if value functions um but there's
really three
important things to keep in mind the
first is that when you create the new
client
you only have to give one valid ip into
the into the fcd cluster
and then you have to call sync cluster
and sync cluster reads
uh it talks to the first ip that it can
talk to
and then it caches a list of all the
other
machines in the cluster so you can this
is a way of
making sure that if one of the nodes
within the cluster goes down
you're able to continue making queries
against it it caches a list of
additional ips
some different consistency levels if
you're doing gits
within fcd you may say uh do a git
on a follower and that follower may have
a slightly older value
if it was partitioned or whatever for
some time so
um you can actually redirect all of your
reads to the master so you
always have the most like consistent
view of the system
um but uh by default it defaults to weak
consistency so you can talk to any of
the
peers within the cluster again
you won't ever get a value that's wrong
you will only ever get values that are
slightly out of date
and then and then it has the regular
operations you'd expect so
after you do new client sync cluster
then you can do set git delete create
and it's pretty much just a thin wrapper
on the http
field client the next interesting thing
is go raft so if you want to like
go nuts and create your own copy of etcd
in about 300 lines of go you can
actually create a thing on top of raft
that has a that uses the same log
and this is a consensus algorithms that
cd does
and over http like create a really
really simple key value store
and you know build something that
integrates directly with your
application
there's two major things that you need
to do if you're going to implement go
raft
the first is there's raf.server and
really the only important api there you
pass in some constructors and
various information like ip addresses
and stuff but the important thing is
there's server.do
and server.due means you get a request
say like
uh set the value to set a value
so you have two parameters like a key
and a value
you pass you make a command which is set
you pass in all the additional data like
the name and the value
you call server.due and then go raft
handles everything else for you
it uses an http transport by default
and so out of server.due you'll get out
either
a success object or an error and on air
it means that the rest of the cluster
doesn't
didn't apply the command and on success
you can return to 200 to you
to your users and then the other
important piece of the api is raft
command.apply
and um all this does is every single uh
node with every single peer needs to be
running the exact same code
so that it actually changes the state on
itself
in the exact same way and it's just one
function that gets called by the server
object
that's the the command and then it runs
dot apply on that command
um so if you can build your own thing
why use ecd
well it turns out it's really hard to
like do this all correctly you need to
have
cluster configuration apis how do i add
and remove nodes
obviously just having statically defined
things in your go source code aren't
isn't going to work so well building an
api is hard we're on v2 of fcd's api
already
it turns out it's just these things are
really difficult to build
and you know get all the use cases
correct
yeah profiling and logging um
everything's just
you know building an application um
prototype is easy but it's
details are hard um yeah
so that's that's fcd um
and then of course i have to do my
shameless for us and plug
um so uh
yeah coreos does a lot of open source
stuff pretty much everything we do is
open source everything we do is on
source
um we have 63 repos and we have three
full-time developers myself so we need
help
and we write a lot of go at cd's all and
go all our backend services are in go
we're writing a distributed scheduler
and go
so we have a lot of stuff we're building
a lot of cool stuff and it's open source
and that's that's my slides
you